[MUSIC]
Thank you so much for
joining us as our first
View From The Top speaker of the year.
As you can see by all this interior,
we are very excited to have you.
So Dean Levin mentioned the fact
that you were born in Mexico,
and you grew up as
the eldest of nine siblings
in a working class family
in Southern California.
How has that experience shaped you?
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, well I was one
of the original Dreamers, right?
Before they had cool names for it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But let's be clear,
they did have names for it, they weren't
very, [LAUGH] they weren't very nice.
I think environment.
I think how you grow up,
who you grow up with has a meaningful
impact on who you are as a person.
There's a lot of you in this room,
you've all had very different upbringings.
And I know from my heritage,
in particular, I think the Latino
population is one that's very family
oriented, humble, in general.
And again, more importantly,
just loyal, sometimes to a fault.
And that has all shaped me, and
then the hard work aspect of that.
And so those are my foundations,
I didn't know to do anything else.
The concept of entitlement when
you're an original Dreamer,
not particularly strong in your world.
So it did shape me into who I am, and
it does affect how I make
decisions to this very day.
I think I make a lot of decisions,
and we as a corporation make a lot of
decisions that are founded on some
of that upbringing that I have.
>> And like some of the students
in the audience today,
you were also the first in
your family to go to college.
And you were deciding between
some great universities,
the Stanford of the East,
as Dean Levin adequately put it, and USC.
You chose USC,
were the Boston winters too cold?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, on the West Coast,
there was a better football program,
at the time,
[LAUGH] clearly not the case now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> No, you know what,
the story behind that is, again, being
in a first-generation, which I hear some
of you in the room are first-generation
undergrads, raise your hand.
Huge respect, guys, it's a big
responsibility for you and your families.
But not knowing, I mean, literally, the
way I decided that I had to go to college,
I was walking down the hallway late
to a class, and Mrs. Duckworth,
one of my high school counselors,
stopped me and said, are you Oscar?
And it's like, crap, I'm in trouble.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> because why else do high school
counselors stop you, right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> We had just taken those PSATs, or
whatever, and she goes, where are you
thinking of going to college?
And my answer was,
honest to goodness, what's a college?
My upbringing, my neighborhood,
it wasn't just the Latino thing,
it was just where we lived.
It just wasn't something you did.
You went high school, you got married,
you had kids, and you lived happily ever
after, and that was great, but
this offered me insight and a view.
And to this day, I hold her in high degree
of respect for taking me down that path.
She helped me with applications and
all sorts of things to get there, and
that's how I decided to go to college.
Now the choice of where and where,
that was just my story of when I went to
the other school, was just hilarious joke.
I mean, talk about two country rubes.
I grew up in Huntington Beach,
I was a surfer kid, right?
I mean, imagine Harvard Yard and
somebody in shorts,
flip-flops, a T-shirt, and hair down
to here [LAUGH] with a blue collar dad.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Even then, at a young age,
I knew that you have to find your way,
find your spot, and go there, and
that just didn't feel like the way.
And no regrets, that was it, SC was great.
>> Yeah, and
you had a heart attack 38 days
after taking over as the CEO of United.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] I love this.
>> Gotta cover the personal.
Gotta cover the personal.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
that was interesting.
[LAUGH]
>> And you then had a heart
[INAUDIBLE] right?
>> As a career thing,
I don't recommend that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, and then you would have
a heart transplant on your
birthday in early 2016.
>> Yeah, so this Saturday night, a couple
of Mondays ago, the 15th of October,
marked my third anniversary with
having the actual heart attack.
We don't celebrate it as much,
but it gets raised.
It's an emotional day
because you realize what you
have versus what could've been,
like not be here.
This coming Saturday night,
my transplant doctor, my cardiologist, and
some of my very close friends, and
of course, my family, were celebrating.
Elton John is going on his last tour,
and so we're celebrating
something on that regard.
But yeah, that was crazy.
Life is, and all of our plans, and all the
things that you're doing are wonderful.
I'm telling you, I know you hear all these
axioms, and all these superlatives and
broad about live life to its fullest,
and BOLO, YOLO, and all that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] You know what,
there's a degree of truth to those things.
You never going to know what's going to
happen, and that was my situation.
But yeah, 37 days, and
then the transplant on my birthday.
There's a degree of fortunate,
of blessings,
of being lucky that are important in life,
and I am all of those and
damned glad to be here, as they say.
>> Yeah, so how have your perspectives and
behaviors changed day-to-day?
>> They really haven't.
I think I do appreciate life,
in general, more.
And there's moments of sort
of personal emotion and
drama when I celebrate anniversaries like
that, or when I have to tell a story or
I have to visit someone in the hospital
that's going through something like that.
It's not only a physical issue with you
personally, it also is emotional, and
then it impacts all your loved ones.
And it's important, I think,
to keep a very positive attitude.
So all of that, I do a lot more.
I go to hospitals, literally,
all over the world, and I'll see folks and
talk to them.
Just by the nature of what I do in
my usual energetic rambling self,
people look, it's like hey,
he looks normal.
And when they know what I've been through,
it's a bit of a motivator for people to
get out of their funk because, I'm telling
you, doctors are very conservative,
and they'll tell you all of
these things you shouldn't do,
like I shouldn't be in any enclosed
spaces with a lot of people, airplanes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I shouldn't be hanging around with
a bunch of [INAUDIBLE] It's like
everything I'm not supposed to do,
I couldn't possibly live without doing.
And that's my choice, and
my doctors generally keep up with me.
But it is an important part of, again,
back to the question you raised earlier
with regards to who you are as a person.
Things like that should shape you and
change you, but who I am,
how I approach things,
that had nothing to do with that.
And they asked, all my loved ones,
have I changed?
And they're like no, you're still the same
nut crazy person that I've always been.
>> Yeah, so I want to talk about
sort of how your personality, and
that thinking, and that process led
you to take the role at United.
So when you took over as CEO,
you inherited a company that was
still struggling to overcome some of
the challenges from
the merger with Continental.
And it's not common for airline CEOs
to come from outside of the industry.
Why did you believe it was
the right job for you?
>> I think it's back to my fundamental
foundation of who I am and
what I think I can do, and
advice I give to all of you.
You really have to know who you are,
it's the old know thyself thing.
And I always did, know thyself, comma, and
then I would write a really big
really with an exclamation point.
Not the self that you think and you
want to project to others that you are,
the real self.
The real self in the middle of
the night and your mind's going,
we are all Petty and jealous and
greedy and angry, all of those things.
Those are pure, wonderful human qualities.
The more you understand yourself, the more
you know your predilection in those areas,
I'm telling you, it's the best of
yourselves when you know that.
I think part of maturity,
I think part of growing up,
I think part of having success, you're
able to have these conversations and
I'm telling you, know yourself.
Really!
And when you do, and so
back to the application of me.
I know what I love, I know what I like.
I love the work that we're
doing with the railroad.
But it was a railroad.
It was a B2B, it was freight.
It was very industrial,
very labor oriented.
We'd take it, we had great runs
as the dean mentioned with regards
to what we had done financially.
But there was always something missing for
me.
And I miss the things from my Coca-Cola
and Pepsi cola days, branding mechanism,
marketing, connecting with other humans.
I thought that was really important.
And, more importantly,
being on the board, I saw some of
the frustration in our employee base.
I saw some of the frustration
with our customers.
And I certainly saw where,
again, back to knowing myself.
What do I get the most energy from?
Well, it is capturing the hearts and
minds of many,
many folks in a large organization,
and I'm thinking, I can do that.
And then I had a couple board members
who were really instrumental in
another sort of initiative,
objective of mine in my life, is how
do you make a difference in this world?
And from what platform can you make it,
and we all have different platforms, and
we can all do different
goods in different areas.
But taking a big brand like United,
driving the turn around,
having success,
gives you a platform to really advocate.
To really do good things for
the community, do good things for
the environment, for you name it.
I now have a voice on a platform
that I wouldn't have without that.
And one of our board members,
a guy named Walter Isaacson,
you guys may have heard of him, arguably
the best living American writer today.
He called me and for two hours, he just
berated about taking this role because
I was literally going to be the CEO
of this next company, like in days.
And he's like,
you have the opportunity, Oscar,
to change the face of American capitalism.
And that's only something like
an author of his renown would say,
and I'm like, well dang, that's okay.
I was just hoping to get free flights or
something.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But when he said that,
and it's actually sparked a lot
of conversations that I've had,
not only with my employees,
but in general.
I like to say things like,
we're building a company that's not
only profitable, but principled.
And that you can be both.
And more importantly,
that by being principled,
you can actually be even more profitable.
And as you guys get into your career,
as you're starting mid or beginning to
reemerge from school back into the work.
It is becoming an ever-increasing
level of attention from
the new generation that you bring, right?
It's not just the product,
it's not the what you do,
like we do in but
it's also the how you do it.
And I think I can do both.
And so that was an opportunity that
I think I had at United that I may or
may not have had, really, at CSX.
because you probably wouldn't have me here
if I was at CSX, just saying, I think.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, Dr.
Parker knows me, so maybe I would be.
[LAUGH]
>> I want to
come back to the platform
discussion in a little bit,
but the phrase that you used, the road to
changing the face of American capitalism.
That road hasn't been the smoothest road,
aside from the personal challenges.
>> Turbulence, we call it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Turbulence, yes, exactly.
There were a series of
incidents last year,
including the forced removal of
a passenger on a United flight, and
separately, the death of
animals on United flights.
And I guess what I'm curious about is,
what lessons, you've publicly acknowledged
and apologized for this on many occasion.
But for the students, what lessons have
you learned through that experience?
>> First and foremost, and when we talked
before hand with Liz and Patrick, I said,
there's nothing off the table.
Ask me whatever the heck you want, period.
That's like, there is nothing that I'm,
anything of value,
because everything we do is learning.
There is turbulence in
everything that we do.
That situation has sparked what I believe
will be the major cog in United's
turn around over time is that it
got our collective stuff together.
We are such a big company with
big operational requirements,
where safety and security have to
be our topmost objectives, right?
Has to be.
Policies and procedures are rigorous,
they're demanding, and more importantly,
they're constrictive and
they don't give you a lot of room for
what we're trying to build now,
which is a caring culture.
And so in that particular instance,
the learning was, we let our policies and
procedures get in the way of doing
the damn right thing, right?
Who in their right mind would bring the
police, and we all saw the video, right?
I mean, 500 million views in China,
I was out visiting and
I'm like,
that doesn't teach you something, it does.
But it was a catalyst to what we've
established from that point forward.
We've established so
many more customer oriented.
Our philosophy and our next journey after
we've done what we've done so far is,
I want to make you, we want to make
you feel better about flying us.
What does that mean?
Put that in your spreadsheet.
You can't, but you can because if you
think how we built this company to today
the first thing I did is I regained
the trust of my employees.
That was the first big
saying to Wall Street.
And Wall Street went just apoplectic,
like, what the hell was that?
He was from outside industry,
doesn't know what he is doing and
the first thing he says,
he's going to be nice to people?
And so, what's the return on that?
Well, you fast forward a year later,
our operations are,
we settled our union contracts.
Our operations are doing best.
We've led the last two years
in an on time originations.
We're getting our planes out on time.
And we haven't invested
a huge amount of money.
We've invested in human capital, right?
And getting those trust.
So build the trust of employees,
get that right, build your operations.
Then build a strategy,
a business strategy.
Which all of you love, right?
That's the sexy part.
That sexy part, it don't work without
the human capital underneath it.
And that's another thing that we
always forget, is that, trust me,
in that large of an organization that's so
spread all over God's green earth,
literally, because we're a global company.
You have to get that right and
then build from that.
That's the foundation for
the things that we've been doing and
this next journey is about the customer
and making you feel better.
That will probably be the most arduous and
difficult thing,
because it's hard to measure.
You tell me everyday.
And you can tell me, I mean MPS is such
a hard thing because if your coffee wasn't
the right temperature, if somebody sitting
next to you had a dog that was the size of
Bosnia, I'm in again trouble for
saying, nothing against Bosnia.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But there's saving,
all of you are frequent fliers, you all
have your views about what's right,
we're chatting in the back about, if I
ever write a book, I'm going to title it,
there is no good deed that goes
unpunished in this business.
because if I do something for
customers, Wall Street gets upset.
If I do something for Wall Street,
employees and customers get upset.
So it's always this constant thing and
you're a demanding, wonderful crowd.
And so my thing I would tell you is that
people like to catch you in these kind of
conversations, especially on national TV.
They will ask you don't you think
the customer is always right?
And I said, you know what, unfortunately
in this day and age, safety and
security are paramount.
And to the extent that we can,
after taking care of those two, we want to
put you at the center of everything we do.
And that's a difficult task, but
you have to understand, safety and
security are key.
I'd love to have you just
show up at the airport and
get on any damn plane you want.
Yeah, come on in, get on.
Southwest does that, I think but.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Sorry.
He's going to come after me.
[LAUGH] So, gosh, we've got so
much to do still.
>> Yeah, and how do you balance
That what you just discussed.
So investing in a better customer
experience while maintaining the cost
discipline required for
profitability in the short term.
Expectations from Wall Street in
a highly competitive industry,
how do you balance that?
>> See, this is where these
are the things that we need
to learn more of even at
this relatively young age.
So I call that debate NPS
net promoter versus EPS,
because in our world that's the tradeoff.
I mean sometimes you just
have this decision where
do I put more seats in the airplane?
Well you don't like that, but
density, and overhead absorption, and
all the things that we
know makes sense for us.
So how do we balance those two things,
well they're trade offs.
And more importantly for us at United,
what we're doing is we're listening to you
our customers,
like what's important to you?
Does this matter to you,
does it really, how do we do this?
And then when we roll things out,
we test it with a lot of different folks.
We just introduced something
called better boarding.
And you're like,
how boring is that, right?
Boarding, really?
Well it's one of
the highest stress points.
How do I know that?
I asked you.
And it's going like gangbusters.
Well you went from five to two and
everybody's gone from two to three and
a half.
Everybody's done this all the time.
But they haven't done the secret sauce.
And why ours is working is I spent,
my team spent eight months
working with customers and
with gate agents who do what?
They do this for
a living every single day.
They know how things board and
what works and what doesn't so
our really smart people with the flows and
the regressions and the statistical
analysis that says this or that.
The first sign of a plan first falls
apart at the sign of the enemy and
the enemy is our own people,
it's like this is stupid.
This doesn't work,
why don't we try this one or we try that.
And so the concept of involving
folks is it requires patience.
It requires you putting your ego and
your intelligence off to the side.
You're all going to come out of
here with a Stanford degree got,
you guys have had a massive leg up.
But if you go back into your workplaces,
what I call, all asses and elbows, right?
Elbowing people out of the way
because you're so damn smart.
I'm telling you, one of the things that
we learn as we gain more experience.
One of the saddest things that you have
is middle to senior middle managers who
lament the fact that their careers
have not gone like they planned.
And they look around at everybody else.
I'm so smart, I'm so capable.
No one recognizes that.
Ladies and gentlemen, I'm telling you
it is a meritocratic world out there.
People notice quality.
People notice leadership.
People reward it to this very day.
There's pockets with bias,
and racial things, and
then sex, all of that stuff, no question.
But in general,
as a whole, people can get ahead because
you made an effort to get ahead.
All of those axioms about treating others,
and not having an agenda and working,
all that sort of thing.
But it's the saddest thing when
people are at that age and
then they just haven't figured
out the EQ side of the thing.
You have to make yourself
the kind of person
that people are willing to come up to and
provide advice.
I run a really big company, and you'd be
appalled at some of the conversations
that people have with me
when someone's upset.
They will yell at me,
they'll stand there, and they'll do this,
and I am loving every minute of it.
Because at the end of the day,
sharing is caring, right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> And if you're yelling at me I still
have a shot at you, it's like, and that
has made the biggest difference in our
company because they know
they can have that output.
And then once you do it you begin
to capture hearts and minds.
And then when they ask them to do it,
we ask ourselves to do things it's
a lot easier way of doing it so
it's a long question to one I don't
even remember what you asked.
>> [LAUGH] That's okay, so
I do have to admit to the audience that I
am a United loyalist and status holder.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I know, I know.
I know, firsthand, how a motive-
>> He's from Boston.
The first thing why do you
have a hyphenated last name.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That was actually his first question
to me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Another trick to interviews,
always turn the tables.
[LAUGH]
>> Yes, exactly.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I do know, firsthand, how a motive and
even tribal people can be about
their airlines However, some
have had as we've discussed, some very
negative experiences with United and some
have even stated that they would quote,
unquote, never fly the airline again.
Why should they reconsider?
>> A funny thing, so over time you get
to know people everywhere and some of
the SNL cast I become friendly with and
everybody knows Weekend Update, right?
If you go back to the time when
they reported on the DOW incident.
That's the flight where we had to,
a bad flight.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Earlier in the week,
somebody had found a scorpion
in one of our overhead bins.
And so, he leads with this.
And tonight on the news, United Airlines
found a scorpion on the thing.
And then he kind of smiles and
he's thinking, honestly,
that wasn't the worst news of the week for
United.
And they were brief and just mentioned
that, they were very nice to us,
they just mentioned it briefly
as they do for everyone else.
And then he stares into the camera,
and he goes I will never fly, and
it's with a serious face, pause, pause,
until they have a good price to wherever I
want to go, then of course I'll fly there.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There's a guy that use to
run Spirit Airlines which he-
>> [LAUGH]
>> He would carry around these 12 letters
and he would open one of the letter and
it would be somebody saying
I'll never fly this airline.
>> Yeah.
>> None of this and the remaining 11
letters were from the same customer
over the course of two or three years.
The economic impact,
and the price of things makes a difference
to all of us, there's no question.
You may not fly someone again or whatever.
People are very emotional about this
business, it's very personal to them,
which is why our purpose and
mission is about connecting people.
Not the physical connection from point
A to point B, but connecting you,
as a human being, to something that's
really important to you somewhere else,
and that's the foundation
of our shared purpose.
Then again, back to my previous comment,
involve 90,000 people, telling me,
telling us, what was important to them.
So connecting people in that more
personal way, and then uniting the world.
Which is an interesting thing that came
out because it's really led me and
us to be able to do a lot of.
Take stands in DACA, Dreamers,
the separation of children.
Gun control and some of the issues that
surround that, because when you have
a shared purpose that's uniting the world
that your 90,000 employees had told you,
it gives you a responsibility
to take action.
And take a position on
some of those things.
>> So I want to transition into speaking
about some of the management and
leadership challenges, and some of
the things that you've done recently.
Many do not realize that
the flight attending crews from
the United Continental merger continued
to work separately for over eight years.
That is, until earlier this month
when you successfully finalized
the deal with the unions.
How did you succeed in
reaching a deal after so
long, and can you share some
negotiating tips with us?
>> So the actual contractual deal
was signed a couple years ago when
we agreed on the contract.
Implementing the contract
was what just transpired.
>> You got 26,000 people,
flight attendants who are the front,
the face, the brand to some degree.
Coming from two different cultures.
All of you will study mergers and
acquisitions, we'll do all the math,
the synergies, how cost can be.
All the things that we like to do.
The human integration of different
cultures Along with the systems that
support them are very critical in how you
handle those and how you manage them.
Because there's so much pride and
so much more history and so
much more resistance to change in those
kind of mergers and integrations.
So it took us a while.
The contract had been going on for
five years.
And when I came, it's just my style, this
is where history will always follow you.
So I had spent ten plus
years at a railroad
where we were largely union oriented.
And unions tend be headed by the same
people across on a national level.
When a union from one company,
when you switch to another company,
calls the union people at that other
company and say, that's a good guy,
he's going to work with you.
Huge, huge benefit to
starting a calculation.
So I don't make that up.
I don't do that.
It's just the way I work.
And the way you work with people,
now, my dad was a union meat cutter.
My uncle was head of
the IBEW in California.
Started unions in Los Angeles,
literally when people were getting
killed for organizing things.
So I grew up in that environment.
I've seen the value of it to some degree,
I also see some of the deficiencies
as we move forward.
But nevertheless, it's the world
they've chosen and you have to admire,
you have to respect it, more importantly
you have to acknowledge it, right?
Seek first to understand,
then to be understood.
And we don't do that, you're a union guy,
you clearly you don't have
my best interest in mind.
You know what?
Try it.
And I think once you've built
that little bit of that history,
it made a difference
when we came to United.
And we settled that five year contract
in one year and it wasn't usurious.
It wasn't giving everything away.
It was very fair contract for both,
which is the way it should be, right?
A fair day's pay for a fair day's work.
And the only thing that needs to be
negotiated is what's a fair day and
what's fair pay.
[LAUGH] That, ladies and gentlemen,
many books written on that.
But having a relationship to start
the conversation is much easier than not,
in my mind.
>> So being located in Silicon Valley,
Stanford students are often drawn into
the start-up and the technology
companies in this area after graduation.
But why should we consider working for
a more established company,
such as United, instead?
>> Well again,
back to the concept of know thyself.
What makes you tick?
If you're just following, [COUGH] again,
I have to be careful because my children
have all become bankers and consultants.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Not that anybody wants to do that here.
>> And tech is a great space.
And if you're good at it,
you really love it, and
it's something you really want to do?
And it really motivates you, and
gets you going, go do that thing.
The sooner you learn that what you love,
and what you want to do, and
what makes you passionate,
and you go do that?
I'm telling you, you're young,
you have lots of life left.
You go do something just for the money,
just because what's your friend,
that's just currently what's hot?
You'll wake up some time in that career,
and
say, dang it,
I wish I had done something else.
So again, back to,
nobody knows yourself better than you.
So think hard about those things and
if that's what you want to do, wonderful,
go do it.
It's all great training ground.
But sometime between then,
it's kind of like choosing
a major in undergrad, all right?
Go try all the different things.
But at some point in time the school calls
you, the dean calls you and says, dude,
you gotta pick.
Life won't tell you that, life will
let you go on, but at some point in
time your personal well being, how you
reflect with the people around you,
how you're production to your community.
And more importantly,
how you interact with your loved ones,
and you all all have loved ones,
it makes a meaningful difference if
you're doing something you really like.
I love what I do.
I won't say, it's a very difficult job,
[LAUGH] because of all the factors
that we face, all over the world.
There's not a single exogenous factor
that doesn't affect an industry like us.
We're always working with that.
But you're right, my foundation is the
energy that I derive from my people and
that's what I love to do.
That's why I chose to come here from CSX.
That's why I choose to continue.
That's why I chose to come back
from dang I almost died, right?
I mean, who comes back from a heart
transplant to do this stuff?
Well again, it's just who I am.
And it's good to know that because you'll
have decisions in your life that will
require you to make some tough decisions.
You can go read all the books and
talk to all your wonderful professors.
All of the advisors, all the counseling
you could possibly get, but man,
it always comes back to you.
[LAUGH] And so and it's great,
you're the best at it about
making decisions for yourself.
>> But this is still Silicon Valley, so
I do have to ask a question
about the future.
You have worked in travel and
transportation for many years now, and
my question is, what do you think will
be different about the transportation
industry, say 20 years from now?
>> Gosh, it'll be completely
radically changed, right?
I mean, from, I hosted Dara from Uber and
a guy named Dennis Muilenburg
who runs Boeing.
You guys know Dara and Oscar?
There's some first name
people out there and so.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Mostly because Dara's last name is
literally unpronouncable.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I had them both at an event
down in San Diego, we talked about
the future of transportation.
And when you hear them talk
about airplanes that fly
in space to literally flying cars,
one's building the software,
one's building the actual vehicle,
they can do that.
So the Jetson's, somebody remember
those cartoons a long time ago.
I've read about them, I just, somebody.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so there's just so
much technology that's
going to be in our future.
I think the way I approach
technology is two-fold.
One, whatever's new, whatever's hot,
whatever's applicable to us, let's roll.
I mean we've got Palantir
here in the valley.
We came out and
visited about a year and a half ago and
interviewed all sorts of different
folks with all this great technology.
Big data, artificial intel, all those
wonderful buzzwords, they can do that.
I'm looking for things that are relevant.
It's what I call it relevant innovation or
relevant technology,
that's relevant to you,
my customer, today.
50 years from now, 10 years from now,
there'll be something more.
I don't want to wait for you for 5,
or 10, or 50 years to be my customer.
I want to you to be my customer now.
So what is it that I can do that's
really healthy and worthwhile for you?
So I have things, we know so
much about you, in a non-creepy way.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I know all your flights.
I know whether you've been upgraded,
I know how your flight went.
And so I have an app and
when I sit next to you, I know all that.
I know your last five flights.
And I know everybody is sitting around and
before I get on an aircraft.
I check everyone and
what I see is red, yellow, green.
It's as simple as that.
And it says, here's a red.
Hey, you flew from San Francisco back
to Chicago a month and a half ago, sir.
Sorry about that, do you want to tell me,
and so I bring it up.
And they're like, whoa,
I don't even remember the flight, but
you start a conversation.
But the fact, it's that
personalization that's important.
So take that conversation and
make it even better.
So I know all of that about you.
So why can't I call you if you're
a traveling, road warrior person,
why can't I call you on a Thursday
evening when you're leaving on a Friday?
And what are the stressors, right?
Traffic, parking, security,
upgrades, all of those things right?
Are you on time, all that sort of stuff.
Well, I have enough data to be able
to proactively call you on a Thursday
afternoon and say hey, ma'am,
I've seen that over the last five flights
we haven't been able to upgrade you.
You're a valued customer.
I want you to know that A,
you have your upgrade, B and
I'm working with TSA on this.
I'm going to get you through
security in a different line.
And by the way, because we're partners
with Uber and Lyft, here's a code for
your Uber so that you have a car, you
have security and you have your upgrade.
The night before you're going on a flight.
How better do you sleep that night?
Now, again, for all of you that
travel a lot, you'll recognize that.
But that, to me, is relevant tech, and
that's how you put all this big data and
management, thereof,
how you put it to use.
Not for this grandiose,
how do I extract more revenue from you?
Which is important and
we'll do that concurrently.
But more importantly, I want you to-
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's a business school, right?
>> But again, it's a win-win, right?
And when I say I want you to feel
better about flying with me,
that's something that
you'll feel better at.
[INAUDIBLE] Hey listen, I was kind of
pissed because I haven't been upgraded,
all of a sudden they called ahead of time,
knew what was going on, helped me out.
So that's a vision that
we're working towards.
And so technology is a great
advantage in all those places.
It has to scale.
We are massive.
Just so big, it's not even funny.
So we have to make sure we do,
we're able to work with some.
And the association is great.
We've gotta have Boeing,
Microsoft, and everyone else.
But we're always looking for
someone else, too.
And so it's exciting to see what
excitement's going on around here.
>> So you mentioned your platform, the
platform that you've been given as the CEO
of United, and I want to transition
to talking about some of the larger
things out in the world that you have
played a role in having conversations
about including the fact that United is
a leader and its efforts to reduce carbon
emissions and recently committed
to having it's emissions by 2050.
But a recent UN climate report
suggests that we only have until 2030
before we start to see the catastrophic
and irreversible effects to warming.
So you are a leader but can and
should you do more to reduce an offset?
>> I'l start with a humorous
approach back to my SNL.
Michael Shay said this.
He goes have you heard?
The planet's dying in ten years and
then he says why don't I care?
[LAUGH] We don't, and
he goes to say humorously.
Because you can't say
everything's going to die
because no one cares about everything,
they care things that are all on me.
You should watch it, it's pretty funny.
I'll tell you my evolution on this.
Personally and really as a company.
First and foremost,
we burn four billion, now-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Gallons of jet fuel, not regular fuel,
jet fuel a year.
So carbon footprint, dude, I have a
giant-size whatever issue in that regard.
I also made a business, and
a lot of money for a lot of investors,
moving fossil fuels, coal, for
instance in the railroad space.
And at that time it was sort
of my bias to disregard or
disprove the concept of global
climate change and any risk thereof.
I've evolved, I mean,
I still have a big carbon footprint.
I just see what we are doing as a planet.
You just can't deny the fact that the
hardware, whether it's industrialization,
all the different things that we're
doing are creating a bigger risk.
This planet will burst at some point
in time, I don't know when it is.
So the questions Al Gore,
in my conversations with him, are simple.
He says do you believe in climate change?
Can you do something about it?
And will you do something about it?
And so for me, and I think for
our company, do we believe it's real?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah I can argue the cyclical
nature of global warming, and
cooling over many centuries and
all of that.
But the difference is man made emissions,
it all becoming more prevalent, and
more impactful.
So yes, I believe in it,
we believe in it as a company.
Can you do something about it,
it's like I don't know,
we burn four billions of fuel
can we really do something?
It's like, yes you can.
So bio-fuels are in their infancy but
we're the leading folks to invest
in companies that manufacture it.
We just flew from here to Zurich
a couple of weeks ago on a fossil fuel.
It isn't quite scale or economic enough.
But our 2050 mission, to your question,
it's going to take a while.
But will you do something about it?
I, we are choosing that
that's going to be done.
And what's cool about it, because
California anointed surfing as the state
sport which I did a lot of that so
I was very happy.
So our president Jana Lampkins
here had a great idea,
why don't we fly surfboards free?
And as a complete different gesture,
guess who picks up on that?
There you go, somebody.
And now for the skiers,
we'll have to work on that.
But, it's a long way away, but
you gotta start somewhere.
And by me doing it in this industry,
hopefully it a lot of
heavy carbon footprint companies
to begin to ask the question,
do you believe, can you do something,
and will you do something about it.
>> Yeah.
Immigration has also been a hot button
issue, and you have been vocal.
You have come out in support of DACA.
You also refuse to let the US government
fly immigrant children who had
been separated from their families
at the border on any United flight.
What responsibilities to executives of
public companies have when it comes to
taking a stand on these social and
political issues?
>> I mention the profitable but
principled earlier.
My opinion and I do it on the basis of
the strength of what we've been doing
in the business, and creating shareholder
value, creating customer value.
And on that foundation of accomplishment,
and
success, in the terms that some
people want to look at it.
I see a responsibility, we see a
responsibility, my employees see a duty by
the nature of shared purpose of connecting
people and uniting the world, and
I have every freedom from our corporation
to do what we think is the right thing.
And what's hard about it is that
it is not without its issues.
You take a position on anything,
now a days,
and the social media world
lights up with negative.
Haters are going to hate,
and boy, do they.
And so immigration and
things like that, because of my
heritage become identity politics,
right, so you quickly discontinued.
Things are taken out of
context all the time.
But you know what, if we're not building,
and showing our next generation
of leaders, that you are in this room,
that you should be certainly profitable,
but principled, that we shouldn't
think about those social causes?
Regardless of what they are, whatever
extreme that you can't voice it and
I'm always very careful to not make
pronouncements that are my bias.
If it's my opinion you will
know that it's my opinion.
But there's just it's we teach a lot
of things ,ethics, morals and values.
I'm telling you the intersection that you
come to a fork in the road where you have
to make a decision on
something is a difficult one.
And it's situational.
I don't have a problem with guns or
anything, just whatever your choice is.
But when there's a shooting, and
one of your pilot's family member loses
a daughter who's 14 years old,
I can't stand by and say nothing.
I won't stand by and say nothing.
And despite one person came to our
annual meeting and just berated me.
Warren Buffett said this.
How dare you as a CEO
take a personal approach.
And you said it was.
I said,
it had nothing to do with politics.
It had nothing to do with guns.
That was purely personal.
Somebody lost a loved one.
I can't stand by.
I won't stand by, and the team,
the family that I belong to
won't let that happen either.
And so, I think we need more of that.
Thoughtful, not so much identity product,
not so much But you know what,
on the right things we have a big
crisis coming with this caravan coming.
I mean the social and
economic instability around us is awful.
This world is interconnected.
You know that because you're
growing up in an environment.
It's so interconnected that something
happens, it's going to affect the US and
there's going to be all hell to pay.
So we will continue to work with all
the right folks to see anything that we
can add to that.
The political issues,
immigration policies.
We'll let politicians manage with that.
I'm just there to pick up
whatever pieces I can.
And I have the full support of
my united family and our board.
And I think that's important to have.
But, again, importantly,
you build that level of credibility.
You build that goodwill by doing
the things that you're all learning to do
here, right?
Strategy, involvement, leadership,
all those sorts of things.
But there's such a big human
component to all of this.
And don't ever forget that, know who you
are, put yourself in the right situations,
because you will face decisions
in your life like I said before,
where you have to choose.
And how you choose, and when you choose,
there will be detractors,
there's no question.
But so damn the torpedos,
let's just do it.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean I am fortunate to be in that
position that what are you going to do?
[LAUGH] I mean, it's like you send me home
to my family that I don't see very often?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Gosh.
[LAUGH] Well, my wife probably has
something to say about that, but.
>> [LAUGH] So
I want to sneak in one more quick question
before we turn it over to the audience.
>> I hear we have a class
coming in here soon.
>> So, yeah.
One of the questions we often
reflect on here at the GSP and
that I think a lot about is this question
of why should people follow you?
>> How do you respond to that question?
>> Why should people follow you?
I think,
I have all these little silly sayings.
I always say proof, not promise.
It's like listen,
I'll stand in front of you, I'm going to
tell you what we're going to do.
And then you don't have to do a darn thing
Because all you're going to see is proof
of what I just told you.
And for the time I've been here,
I can honestly stand in front of my entire
United family and our share owners.
Increasingly in front of our customers
as we do more in that space.
I had said is there anything ever I have
told you that we haven't delivered on?
It's hard to say that, but
I don't say things publically that
we're not going to deliver on.
We're very careful and
review everything we're going to say.
It's important.
That's why people follow you
because they talk to each other.
You telling someone,
you need to follow me because I'm the man.
I'm the boss.
Or I'm the smarter.
I did all these things
to this other company.
All that's part of the equation.
But every human needs a personal
connection, a personal desire.
A heart and a mind connection that
drives someone to what I generally call
discretionary effort.
This is a business where, I have,
they're spread all over the world.
A gate agent back in the back
corner of some airport in Turkey,
I have no control over her and
what she's doing.
All I have is the communications that
we've done, the feeling of family,
the shared purpose and mission,
all of those superlatives and
all those things that keep
people doing business.
Because then, that person,
just like when raising children.
All your parents have let you go, mostly.
[LAUGH] And
you're left to make your own decisions.
Are you making the right decisions?
Some yes, some not.
And so, the why you should follow
me is not a question I ask.
It's like, let me show you, let me prove
to you, and then people follow in droves.
I mean they really do,
it's a really powerful thing when you
capture the hearts and minds of folks.
How you do it versus how I do it,
that's what you have to figure out because
there is no one way of doing it and you
got a lot of talented folks, faculty that
will tell you all those different things.
But my view is you gotta know
who you are and for God's sake,
another thing I say is swing easy.
We try too hard sometimes.
I mean guys in particular get a deep
voice when you ask a question,
well let me tell you sir, relax.
And I say swing easy because if you
play golf, in particular tennis,
if you see the professionals,
they make that effort's effortless.
Right, their swing is effortless.
We in our career sometimes try a little
too hard, especially early on.
Be the person that someone pulls aside and
says hey,
Oscar, you might want to
try this versus that.
You got to be that person
that people are willing to.
If I have a guiding principle or fact of
something that's been done that I've been
so fortunate to have is that across my
career, someone's always pulled you aside.
Especially when you thought
you were all that, right?
I'd been, I was the youngest of this,
and the youngest of that, and all that.
But then somebody, key point if I could,
one boss, it's a pointed story.
I'm sitting at a review,
I just, I'm a 26-year-old kid.
I went from this level at one company,
to this level at Coca-Cola.
And I'm just feeling everything.
And I think everyone around
me is kind of stupid,
because I'm the smartest
thing in the world.
Six months in, my boss pulls me in, we
have this performance review and he says,
hey, you exceed our expectations,
I took a risk on you,
you've been killing it really.
You're crushing it,
before that word was important.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Then he says,
and he closes kind of the book,
and he pulls aside,
he goes but if I could tell you
something on a more personal basis.
And I'm like, he wants me to date
his daughter or something, probably.
>> [LAUGH]
>> No, he said, and this is critical.
He said you know what?
You're really good, but you're not yet
as good as you think you are.
And I was like, excuse me?
That sounded kind of negative.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You're not yet
as good as you think you are.
And I walked out of there, went through
all those seven stages of anger,
all those little things that people do.
But it was critical.
Along life, you've gotta find
the right person that has that desire.
Remember, sharing is caring.
And that made a huge difference,
because I'd walked into an environment
where I thought I was all that.
I was the youngest, and well I recognized
that people around me were incredibly,
deeply, knowledgeable and experienced.
Where my energy could be better,
in fact, it's guided many things
like that, so always make sure,
and don't ask people, like, Hey,
tell me something bad about myself, right?
You just gotta act that way.
And find people, love people around you.
Give them the liberty, give them
the liberty to be honest with you.
You will find more often than not, when
somebody tells you something negative.
And you go, hey honey,
this jerk at work said this about me and
your spouse will go well, honey.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> It’s an important thing, I'm sorry.
>> No, we’d like to take a few questions
from the audience, if that’s okay.
>> Sure.
>> Hi, my name is Edward Silva.
Thank you, Oscar,
I’m an MBA student here at GSB.
And my question is, where with
the United do the new, creative,
even crazy ideas come from, and what
are you doing specifically to foster them?
>> Well they come from
this listening thing.
It's amazing how there's really
cool leading edge innovation and
then there's just basic things that
we need to do right and better.
And so,
most of our people focus on the latter,
it's like the simple things like
this boarding thing I discussed.
And so, getting input from that.
On the innovation side, we started
what all of you around here know, but
it isn't often as prevalent and big 100
year old industrial companies like mine.
The concept of fast failure, right?
Big companies employ people like you to
do all the analytics, and their and this,
and all the studies, and
all these things about an idea.
And you go months into it and
then somebody determines it's a go or
a no go And then maybe you try it or
you don't, but you've wasted so much time.
It's like somebody has kind of
a cool idea, it's like, go.
And so we built a digital sort of group,
it's actually a separate building,
just for many reasons, but
you go in there and just the objective
in those rooms it's just bring ideas.
Put them to, bring them up,
and see how well they scale.
And it's amazing how many things take
hold, but how energetic that is.
And now, in our company,
it's cool to come up with ideas.
Before it was like, well,
management doesn't like it.
You're talking back.
So part of it is culture, but
also part of providing an environment, but
more importantly acting
on that environment.
So once getting back to proof,
not promise.
It's like, yeah,
if you have an idea and it's coming up,
I am taking you everywhere I go and
showing your mug everywhere, it's like,
his idea, this the guy who did it,
this is what he does.
I mean, we have so many wonderful
histories that we tell about our company.
So creating that culture and
all of you are probably more familiar
with it because if you live and
work around here, it's easier to do
that in a smaller younger company.
Hundred year old companies
just don't do that,
might the tenure of my Workforce
the level of education.
All of those things are subject but never
underestimate the power of human caring,
human engagement and
human experience makes a big difference,
especially when it comes time
to dealing with US customers.
>> Hi my name is Jorge Queto and
I'm a first year MBA.
My question is related
to work culture as well.
What do you think is necessary to create
a more inclusive work environment for
Latinos, as well as for people from other
underepresented groups including women,
black people, LGBTQ people,
and undocumented immigrants.
>> Did we miss anybody on that list?
Veterans, disabilities like autism.
Biggest and best supporter I think of
Special Olympics that we come in united
because I believe in that whole breadth.
Yes, it's my heritage and
my natural asset.
I'll tell you,
diversity inclusion, two words.
Diversity and inclusions,
they're two different terms.
Diversity has become, we've made progress,
it's numeric, metric-oriented progress.
I have the largest percentage of female
pilots in the world in aviation.
Yay, it's 8%.
But it's the best.
I relax, right, no?
Diversity's is just not about numbers.
How are my women of color, for instance?
But more importantly,
back to the other word, inclusive.
I go see my women pilots and
I say, hey, yay, did you hear,
you're the largest
percentage in the industry.
Do you think they celebrate that?
No, because when I asked I said,
what else can we do better?
There's always a list of things and
those lists of things are on
the inclusive aspect of it, right?
Am I involved?
Do you value me?
These microaggressions of stopping people.
It's like do you know that women get
cut off in meetings more than anyone?
And you tell it to a guys, he's like no,
it hasn't happened, watch.
And you go back and watch,
it's like dang, we do things like that.
And so part of the thing that we're doing,
and Latinos.
Latinos, by the way,
the millennial thing we all talk about,
guess what the demographic looks like very
soon of millennials versus boomers, right?
Millennials bigger, next year.
73 million versus 72 million.
Guess what the percentage of millenials
are that are Latino in this country,
almost half.
So I don't go tell you you gotta do
this and you gotta hire Latinos.
I tell you it is an economic force
that is a massive proportions.
Why Dara from Uber and Dennis Mullemberg
were in the meeting with me,
is because they recognize that it's
a A $2 plus trillion market, Latinos are,
and 56 is in the transportation
leisure business.
So it's a right market, right?
Where you're all looking for growth and
for your companies and all the stuff,
well, you go fish where the fish are.
And the fish have a little
spicy salsa next to them.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] I can say that.
But it comes across all cultures and
everything.
There's just so much to be done.
I'll tell you,
and I'm talking about it tonight in
San Francisco with Women in the Workplace.
My next mission is to some degree,
because we have one of the highest
percentage of women in the workplace.
Again, the numbers all work out for us.
And a way, not the point,
harassment, sexual harassment for
a flight attendant for
people is still an issue.
There's still idiots that sit next
to people and think they can touch,
think they can do and ask and
say things that they shouldn't.
And there's still people
that sit next to someone and
don't want to sit next to someone because
of their race, color, sex, or creed.
Those people have no time,
nowhere, no business.
You can go fly elsewhere because that's
just not something we're going to do.
Hard to do in this market because I have
to remove them from the aircraft, right?
And then we have that whole other issue.
>> [LAUGH] What else?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> So
I'd like to close by doing a quick
lightning round if possible.
>> Sure.
>> So this or that style.
Aisle or window?
>> An aisle because if you sit
next to me you just get abused.
I mean, people reach over, customers and
employees will reach over you,
stand in front of you.
So I always sit at the window so
I can just talk to people and
not disrupt my fellow
flying person next to me.
And yes I do fly my own
airline all the time.
Gotta eat what you cook.
Not all airline executives do that.
[LAUGH]
>> Coke or Pepsi?
>> You know what?
Coke was my last time, so
Classic Coke, no additives.
I watch what goes into other products,
and so,
the stuff in regular Coke is
at least God made, right?
It's natural.
It's sugar.
>> Planes or trains?
>> Yeah,
I got to go with my family, planes.
>> Adventure or relaxation?
>> God, adventure.
[LAUGH] I don't know what that other word.
I do know what that word is.
And after I've done some
adventure something.
Kardashians or The Bachelor?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'd label that the fall of
Western Civilization as we know it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> NorCal or SoCal?
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] I'm a so cowboy.
That's no question.
I love it up here.
I got engaged here,
I went running, walking, jogging.
It's hilly,
I forget how hilly it is downtown, but
the Saint Francis Hotel
is where I got engaged.
So that always brings a lot of memory.
The Carnoelon Room probably most
of you don't even remember,
it used to be at the top of the BFA tower.
>> That's when I started my way
through my, I thought I was so
confident in my request to my
wife to join me in marriage but
I couldn't get the two words out for
a while.
[LAUGH] So
it's always be close in that regard.
>> Then of course the last one,
Delta or American?
No, I'm just kidding, you don't have to.
It has been a pleasure speaking with you
Oscar, please join me in thanking him.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Great job.
[MUSIC]